JON WILEY: Hello.
Welcome to "Designing
for Virtual Reality."
My name's John Wiley.
I'm the principal designer
for Google Cardboard
and Virtual Reality at Google.
Everybody enjoying
their Cardboards?
Hopefully most of you got some?
I think we ran out, so
they were pretty popular.
Awesome.
Also, I recommend, if
you haven't already,
after this, go up and
check out our demo booth.
The jump videos there
are exceptional.
Yesterday, we
actually had the guy
who drove the
actual Rover on Mars
was giving the expedition
on Cardboard for the Mars
expedition, so that was
actually really exciting.
Cool.
Well, welcome.
Thanks for coming today.
Today, we're going to talk
a little bit about what
our team has learned
in the short time
that we've been
working on Cardboard.
So we released Cardboard
about a year ago,
and the momentum
has been tremendous.
It actually really surprised us.
It went from being this 20%
thing that was like, oh, that's
kind of cool, to just having
a lot of excitement around it,
a lot of apps being built,
and a lot of Cardboard devices
out in the world, and
just tremendous growth,
and that's really
exciting to see.
Last year, I was at I/O here
to present material design.
And one of the things
that attracted me
to Cardboard and to VR, if
you think about material
design, its origins
are in the fact
that you're physically
interacting with software.
So the way in which
you respond to it,
you're touching
a physical device
and you're actually
touching the software,
and in that, you kind want
to have the software have
some authenticity, right?
It's going to be
responsive and it's
going to have some physics,
and motion is a first priority
citizen there.
You want to be true
to that interaction.
And the cool thing about that
is that every single time
that computing gets closer to
the way in which we naturally
interact with the world,
that's where the magic happens.
Well, virtual
reality is 10x that.
It's really tapping
directly into the way
we perceive and see the world.
If you can get one
of these demos,
and again, those jump videos,
you have to see them in VR.
That's really
where the magic is.
Near things are near,
far things are far,
and it's really tapping
into that authenticity
of the physical space.
And we really feel like
in terms of creating
delightful experiences, that's
really where the magic is.
When computing gets
closer to the way
that humans naturally
interact with the world,
that's where great
things can happen.
But the inverse is also true.
We raised the stakes in terms
of people's expectations.
We expect reality to not drop
frames, and virtual reality,
if we really want
it to be immersive
and have a great
experience, we want
to make sure that we're
doing the right thing
and we're feeding into
people's expectations
about turning around and seeing
things and how that works.
And so it's easy
to fall into a pit
where actually, you can
create a bad experience,
just as much as it
is possible to create
an amazing experience.
And we've been thinking
about that a lot
since we started
working on Cardboard,
and we're actually really
excited about the momentum
across the entire industry
and lots of conversation
about how to design
great experiences.
And today, we're going to
share what excites us about VR,
and we're also
going to share what
we've learned in the short time
that we've been working on it,
and we hope to continue
this conversation
beyond these walls.
So with that, please
welcome Erica.
[APPLAUSE]
ERICA MORSE: Hi.
My name's Erica.
I'm a designer on
the Cardboard team,
and today I'm going
to be talking to you
about why virtual reality.
With virtual reality,
you give people
one of the most popular
superpowers, teleportation.
Imagine your third
grade self learning
about the Mayan civilization
for the first time,
but instead of
looking at a textbook,
you're standing at the
base of Chichen Itza.
This is actually imagery
from the expeditions
that we announced at
yesterday's keynote.
Soon, teachers will actually
be able to take their students
on virtual tours
around these ruins.
Think about how much more
fun school is going to be.
VR also allows for more
engaging journalism.
Instead of reading about the
earthquake in Nepal, what
if you could go
there and see what
it's like firsthand
on the ground?
Think about the empathy
and sense of civic duty
this could inspire.
And finally, how
about the art world?
Installations that play
with space, light, and color
can only be fully appreciated
in person, or now,
in virtual reality.
So you can transport your users.
You can also give
them experiences
that are physically
impossible in the real world.
How about flying, another
popular superpower?
In a Cardboard app
called Caaaaardboard!--
it has five A's and
one exclamation point--
players get to dive
off of buildings,
and that feeling of falling
continuously is an experience
you can't easily
get in real life.
So those are a few of the many
compelling use cases for VR.
What are you going to make?
I imagine that some
of you have ideas
for apps that will
live entirely in VR,
but I'm guessing that
a large number of you
have existing 2D
apps that you're
thinking about adapting to VR.
And to those folks,
my tip to you
is to start small and
focus on introducing
VR content that for your
app is a game changer.
To give you a better idea
of what I'm talking about,
let's imagine I have a
hypothetical real estate app.
We have a Map view that allows
you to filter by location.
We have individual
listings with information
about price and size.
We even integrate
with Google Maps,
allowing you to easily get
locations to each house.
All of these tools are
working really well in 2D.
But one part of the app
that would work much better
in virtual reality
is the photo gallery
because compared to
a series of photos,
touring in the home in VR will
give you a much better sense
of scale and layout.
Also, think how
much time you could
save if you didn't have to
physically visit every house
that you're interested in.
Ask yourself if there's
any part of your app
that is practically
begging to be displayed
in virtual reality, and if you
do decide to incorporate VR
into your app, here are some
best practice guidelines.
If you're using an icon to
represent Cardboard mode,
we suggest using the
silhouetted white icon
on the left instead of the
colored icon on the right.
The silhouetted icon
is simpler and it's
in keeping with the
Material Style Guide.
If instead you're using a
text button entry point,
say, something like View
in Cardboard or View
in Virtual Reality,
using the word
"cardboard" will
remind people what
they should be reaching for.
And finally, many of your users
won't have Cardboard, at least
yet, and for these
users, you might
consider hiding
the future entirely
or, if you want to
promote it, direct them
to the Google
Cardboard site where
they can learn what Cardboard
is and potentially get
a Cardboard of their own.
This concept of introducing
VR into 2D apps is still new,
but there are already a number
of apps that are doing it.
On the left,
there's Monzo, which
is an app that allows you to
create digital models of cars,
planes, even catapults,
and they added the ability
to view your final creations
in virtual reality.
And on the right
is Seene, which is
an app that allows you to
create and view 3D photos,
and they also added
a Cardboard mode.
And most recently,
at the keynote
yesterday, we announced
that YouTube will support
Cardboard mode for 360 videos.
In a year's time, over a million
people have gotten Cardboard,
and that number is getting
larger and larger, which
means you have a growing
audience for the apps
that you will dream up.
And as you start building
these VR experiences,
it's important for you to
constantly test them out.
I'd like to welcome Manuel,
who will tell you more
about building VR experiences.
[APPLAUSE]
MANUEL CLEMENT: Thanks, Erica.
OK.
Let's talk about crafting
your own applications.
How many of you make stuff?
I just want to make sure
I'm at the right conference.
So when you build
applications in VR,
it's very important that
you try them as early and as
often as possible.
It's kind of a temptation
to just throw things
together and say it looks really
nice looking at your computer
monitor.
So something we think about
is the design process here,
and we're just getting started.
We want to share some ideas with
you, some things we explored.
Just remember to put it in
Cardboard, put it on eyes.
As you place objects, say, wow,
this is too close, too far.
We'll talk about it in a minute.
So the goal here is to have
genuine empathy for your users.
How do they feel?
How does it really feel?
So although this is about
prototyping and building stuff,
we're building stuff for humans.
Let's talk about humans.
First, I'd like to
talk about convergence.
Convergence is the
inward movement
your eyes make toward
each other when
you're trying to keep sharpness
in objects you're looking at.
You might say it's focus.
So a little experiment.
Put your finger in front of you.
Look at it.
It's sharp.
And then you look at me or
at the stage, unsharp finger.
You see two fingers.
Next one.
Is this comfortable?
What do you think?
So I did not experience this.
I didn't get traumatized, but
let's try to traumatize you.
Put your in front of you
and imagine it's a boulder,
and then bring it
toward your face.
Keep going, keep
going, keep going.
At one point, for
a regular human,
it will be blurry
no matter what.
Basically, things that are
too close to your head,
you can't focus on it,
you can't converge on it.
It's something really
important to think about,
and that's because your
eyes are basically crossing
and you're straining
your eye muscles,
so there's comfort
there as well,
discomfort for your
users, something
to really think
about display stuff.
A few more things
about convergence/focus
is people can only
focus on one thing
at a time, a finger or myself.
Also, switching
between distances.
I'm looking at this
thing right here,
and I'm looking at
people in the back,
and I'm looking
here, and the back,
and actually, the
thing is right here.
If you do this
repeatedly, eventually, it
becomes uncomfortable, and
different people feel it
differently, keep in mind.
Additionally, people are
better at judging distances
between objects that are up
close-- kind of makes sense,
right?
My hand's here or
my hand's here--
than far away-- last
row, second to last.
So the point here as you
build your applications
is to always be aware of
what people's eyes have
to converge on.
That's a good way
to think about it.
How does it relate
to you as developers?
Well, it'll take you less time.
You'll make less mistakes.
You'll always try it and
say, are the eyes converging?
Are people comfortable or not?
So very useful for developers.
So let's share some
prototypes with you.
This is something we
tried a little bit,
and I'm just sharing with
you the design process here.
In this tool we prototyped,
we have these outside rings,
and it presents you with a zone
of comfortable neutral/zero
convergence for maximum comfort.
So you place objects
there and chances are,
when people are focusing
back and forth in that area,
they'll stay comfortable.
So this was fun for us to try.
Additionally, when objects
are too close to you,
it's going to zoom
in at one point,
there's a smaller
red ring, and so
this was us checking things out.
It's a good idea
to show the design
tool at what point things
are too close to the person.
This is just sharing some ideas.
We've learned a lot from this
prototype and other things
we're exploring.
Let's talk about scale.
So in VR, scale
is very important,
something key to think about
as you build your experience.
So there's something called
IPD, Inter-Pupillary Distance,
and it's the distance
between your pupils.
So something interesting
is an accurate IPD
ensures people's sense of
scale matches their perception
of reality in the real world.
That's like regular reality.
But I could be giant.
My head could be massive.
My IPD could be very wide.
Also, it would mean
you guys of the world,
if I had a really large head,
would appear really tiny,
and that's really fun.
So scale is fun.
Have fun with it.
To understand scale
better, something else
we prototyped a bit is, what
if we dropped a human body
inside a design tool?
And we found this is cool.
Very quickly, I
can tell that wow,
this is how big the
person is in the world.
So we learned quite
a bit from that.
It's fun to share with you.
Something else we found is that
standing and seated positions
are pretty important
to think about.
So if you stare at person,
it's like, we really
have a person there.
It's not just for cylinders.
So people may be
sitting in their living
room, unable to turn around,
so you place stuff around them.
Let's talk about
field of view now.
So this prototype
shows two frustums.
Frustums are these
pyramid looking shapes.
Sorry for the math
guys in the room.
I've got to explain
it's like a pyramid.
That's a frustum.
So the narrower one
that you see right now
shows you what you can see
without turning your head.
So I think that in
there is pretty nice,
so you know when you
place an object there,
as you move it into the
field of view of the person,
is the person going to be
having to turn their head?
You build UI, you have that
distance in the green rings,
and then you know if they
have to turn their head
to see anything or not.
The wider one, the
black one there,
shows you what you can see if
you turn your head slightly.
It looks pretty wide.
Actually, it's just turning
your head comfortably.
So it's nice to think
about when people
are unable to turn around as
you build your interfaces.
Just sharing with you
things we're trying.
Hope that's
interesting to look at.
Now let's talk about
the Cardboard Unity SDK.
How many of you have
not used Unity yet,
or are just kind of OK at Unity
and are just getting started?
There's a lot of you.
That's good.
So I went to the Cardboard
website, downloaded this one
file, and I'm importing into
an empty project in Unity.
It has files in
it, lots of files.
They're all very good.
I'm going to highlight
three of them.
There's a demo scene I'll
talk to you about a minute.
There's a prefab
called CardboardMain,
and prefabs are really
awesome for developers.
It allows you to just drag
and drop into your scene,
it's done, pretty much.
You have that VR
rig ready to go.
You've got the eyes set up.
There's a C Sharp
script for when
you guys want to build
your stuff from scratch.
It allows you to drag and
drop to an existing camera.
Maybe you have a
Unity app already,
or maybe you're grabbing
one that you picked up
and you want to port it to VR.
It allows you to turn
the camera into a VR rig
with just one
click, super useful.
So fire up the demo
scene, this is what I see.
So a lot of you haven't
used Unity much,
so this scene is actually
a really nice first VR
project as you're getting
started and once you get going.
It has a bunch of interactions,
including this Gaze input
thing we have going where
you see a reticle-- it's also
called a dot-- in the
air, and it shows you
what you're looking at.
So that's built in.
You just copy and
paste into your scenes
and you've got stuff
running very quickly.
So if I press Play in
Unity, it's really nice.
It runs.
I can see what it would
look like in Cardboard.
I've got the eyes going.
I'm turning my head by moving
the mouse while holding
Alt, just a little tip.
We documented that,
but it's good to know.
And I click on these guys
by clicking on the mouse
and it triggers the
button on the Cardboard.
But you're looking at
a computer monitor now.
Remember genuine
empathy for your users,
like how does it really feel?
So wouldn't it be better
to see this in VR?
Something else we're
working on, and there's
a first version of this in an
SDK we just shipped yesterday,
is support for Unity Remote.
The way this works is I
have the phone in Cardboard,
and I can move the phone around,
and it's reading the neck
movements, and I can edit
in Unity at the same time
as it's in my eyes.
I made the scene much smaller.
I looked down, and
now I became giant.
I didn't have to wait for
a compiling application,
didn't have to wait
for it to show up
on the phone to realize this is
too small, it's big, whatever.
So this just super rapid
development process.
It's very handy.
I love the feature
and you will, too.
So for more information, go to
Cardboard Developer website.
Go there, download
what you need.
There's a lot of documentation.
To summarize, I told you
about a few interesting things
about humans.
I told you about convergence,
IPD, and field of view,
as well as position
of the person.
You saw how easy it is to
create your own Cardboard app
and I shared with you
some of the things we're
playing with there on
the team, including
one that is in the SDK already,
which is the remote control
thing.
It's cool.
So please welcome Alex.
He's going to tell you
about design principles.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX FAABORG: Thank you, Manuel.
This is an absolutely amazing
time to be a designer,
and the reason it's so amazing
is just how new VR design is
and how much we have
to learn and discover.
This isn't the definitive
talk about VR design.
It's still too early for that.
I look forward to being able
to give that talk eventually.
But this talk does
cover what we've
learned so far,
both as a team also
as an industry over
the last few years
as we've been diving
into VR design.
One of the things we found, and
we saw this with the examples
that Manuel was just showing
with the live preview
and design, is
really the best way
to learn about VR
design is in VR itself.
And this was actually a bit of
a challenge for me recently.
I was writing the
style guidelines that
are online on the web
and thinking, man,
it would be a lot easier
to let people actually try
this out instead of trying to
write these long paragraphs.
So today, we have
an announcement
that we're extremely
excited about.
We're releasing something
called the Cardboard Design
Lab the teams worked on.
The great thing
about this is you
can learn about VR
design principles
actually in VR, in
its native habitat.
So we have a bunch
of examples, things
that are very foundational,
things like using a reticle
or keeping the user grounded,
motion, things like that.
We also have a lot of
more advanced stuff
and more immersive concepts,
like guiding the user
with light, spatial,
audio, gaze cues.
So definitely go
download this app
and try out all
of the 10 lessons
that we have built into it to
learn about these principles.
If you're actually
watching this on video,
I would encourage you to
pause and try out the app
and then come back, and
we'll talk about all
of the principles
in much more detail.
So when you're designing
for VR, you're really
designing for the
capabilities of the human
as much as you're designing for
the capabilities of the system,
so it's really important that
you understand your users
and what they're capable of.
So first we'll start
out with a story.
Imagine it's a beautiful morning
hundreds of thousands of years
ago and you wake up and
you're feeling great.
The sun is shining.
You look outside your cave and
you don't see any predators.
That's awesome.
And you're starving so it's
time to start foraging for food.
So you head out and
you find some berries,
these red berries, and you've
never seen anything like this
before.
These look delicious.
So you start eating them and you
realize immediately that things
have gone horribly wrong.
You've got this
ringing in your ears,
your vision's a
little bit blurry,
and the worst part is
everything is kind of wooshy,
like you move and the
world doesn't totally
track correctly.
And this is a really
critical moment for you
because you basically
have two options.
You can eject the berries,
or if you don't, it's
unfortunately game over.
And we've evolved to be
very sensitive to vestibular
ocular disparities.
Motion sickness is actually
a defensive mechanism
that comes through evolution.
And the person that
ejected the berries,
they're our ancestor
because they survived.
So bad input can really cause
a bad physiological response
for users, and this
is something that's
really important with VR design.
Of course, we're familiar
with phones having
an inertial measurement unit.
We have one as well
called our cochlea.
It's sort of a series
of tubes in our ear
and in our vestibular system.
And as we're thinking about
the system as a whole,
we have the phone's
inertial measurement unit.
We also have our own.
We have the screen and
our eyes, and all of this
has to work in tangent, in
unison as part of the system.
So it's really
important that you're
getting good input to the user
based off of their movements
and what they're seeing
because if it doesn't, then
that's going to create bad
physiological responses.
So this is a complex
way of saying always
maintain head tracking.
Never drop frames.
If you're starting to load a
new scene in your application,
it's not OK to freeze all of
a sudden and let that come in.
Be sure that you're
monitoring performance,
that you're always
maintaining head tracking.
It's really, really critical.
If for any reason you
can't, just fade to black
and keep using audio
in your application
because people are very
sensitive to these things.
Another thing to talk about
is motion and the concept
of constant velocity.
So it's kind of strange.
We actually don't feel velocity.
We feel acceleration
and deceleration.
So an example of this is
when you're in an airplane,
you definitely feel the take
off and you feel the landing,
but when you're actually
just flying around,
it doesn't feel like you're
going 500 miles per hour.
You might feel some
turbulence or something,
but the actual
velocity of the plane,
you're not noticing that.
Another example.
We're all, of course,
on the planet Earth.
It's traveling very fast.
If the planet were
to decelerate,
we would definitely feel
that, but while it's
traveling at high velocity,
we're not feeling that at all.
So this fact that we
don't feel velocity
is actually really
important for VR design
as well because if you
have someone traveling
at a constant velocity,
it's not going
to be as disconcerting
as if you're
having lots of acceleration
and deceleration
because they're going to
notice that difference, when,
if in VR they're accelerating
or decelerating, then obviously
in reality, they're
just standing there.
So that can also create
potentially some discomfort.
And everyone's different.
Everyone has different
tolerance levels
for what they find
acceptable with motion,
so it's really important to
try things out with users, even
with constant velocity,
to see how they're feeling
and if it's working.
Another aspect about
motion is definitely keep
a stable horizon line
inside your application.
I'm sorry.
If you don't, it'll--
don't drop frames, either.
So let's talk about vision.
A really common question with
vision that a lot of people
talk about is what
resolution does
the screen need to be for
resolution not to matter?
It's a really good question.
There's two parts of it.
One is field of view.
So again, everyone's different,
but for a lot of people,
field of view of 210 degrees
horizontally by 100 degrees
vertically will
cover everything.
And then in terms of pixel
density, if for every degree,
we had 60 by 60 pixels,
that would be pushing
the limits of our vision.
That would be 20/20.
Some people have better
than 20/20 vision,
so it's in that range of getting
up to 60 pixels per degree.
So something like
a 12,600 screen
by 6,000 with a 210 by 100
field of view would be great.
That's probably
actually overshooting it
because we actually only
have high resolution
vision in our central
vision with our fovea.
Our peripheral vision
is very blurry.
This is assuming that you
had the same size pixels
throughout the entire screen.
You can build a
screen with pixels
that were different sizes.
So that's pretty high,
and we're not there yet.
And as we are on this
progression of increasing
screen technology
with phones, it
seems like it's becoming
harder and harder
to talk about screens.
We, of course, have our
old favorites like VGA,
but the recent acronyms
are getting increasingly
ridiculous, plus we have all the
complexity of optics with VR.
So I'd like to talk
about something
we've been talking
about on the team, which
is a really clear way to talk
about this is just pixels
per degree and the number
of degrees of field of view,
and just focus on
those two things.
So again, if we can get
into 60 pixels per degree,
now we're at an eye
limiting system.
So reality, 60
pixels per degree,
210 degrees field of view.
Let's talk about
some of our devices.
Nexus 5 on Cardboard,
not quite reality
yet, 12 pixels per degree
and 85 degrees field of view.
Nexus 6 on Cardboard
does a little bit better,
increases up to 13,
but more notably
increases the field of
view with the new Cardboard
up to 100 degrees.
Let's talk about
hearing now that we've
talked about vision a bit.
In a way, hearing is
kind of a type of vision.
So the interesting
thing about hearing
is it lets you see the
entire scene around you
all at the same
time, and this can
help you build up a mental
model of what's there
before you've even seen it.
So let's try out an example.
[BELL RINGING]
So you guys all knew that there
was a bell there before I even
turned to look at it.
Let's try it again.
There's supposed
to be another bell.
[BELL RINGING]
Sort of over there.
So we're really good at
positioning audio spatially.
And what's important for
this in terms of design
is if you have something
creating audio in a scene,
you can immediately cue
users in to it being there.
So attaching a bell to your
interface is a bit much.
You could just have
your interface hum
or buzz or something
a little bit,
but you can definitely direct
the user's attention with audio
and you can fill them in
as to the world around them
by using spatial audio.
Let's talk a little bit about
designing the environment.
So one of the first
mistakes we've made
and most people
designing VR make
is you drop user
into the environment
and you're not really
thinking about where you're
going to drop them in
so they immediately
start colliding with an object.
This is very disconcerting
and sort of uncomfortable.
It's not literally uncomfortable
because it's virtual,
but you look down and you see
something coming through you
and it's not good.
You feel uneasy about it.
So we talked a lot about
physiological comfort.
It's also important to talk
about environmental comfort
and the types of things that
make people environmentally
uncomfortable.
So obviously, heights
is a big one for people.
People can be scared of heights.
Also small spaces,
claustrophobia.
Then there's the
opposite of that.
For me, actually, I'm
more with agoraphobia,
large spaces, big, empty rooms.
Imagine working at a desk
with a single spotlight
down on your desk.
That would be very unnerving.
Scale is very interesting.
So when you have
small objects, they
have this sort of
toy-like quality.
They're very fun.
You feel very powerful.
You're this giant.
You have this tiny truck.
But if you invert that,
now it's very different.
You feel very weak and
small and very intimidated
by these big objects.
It's not just
things like trucks.
You could build a user
interface that was really big,
and the user will feel small
and diminished in front of it,
like the interface
itself will make user
feel slightly uncomfortable.
Other things about
environmental comfort.
Obviously, people don't
like to be crushed.
This is an extreme example,
but another example.
I was in a VR simulation and
it was just planets rotating
around.
It was beautiful, but then
suddenly, one of the planets
was coming right out
me, and part of my brain
was thinking, get out of
the way, get out of the way.
You can't turn that off.
And for that moment, it
was very uncomfortable
as I had to remind
myself, no, it's fine.
This planet is just going to
collide straight through me
and everything's
going to be great.
So people don't
like to be crushed.
Also, sharp objects.
People aren't super
fond of those.
For sharp objects in
particular, people
are very protective
of their eyes.
So imagine you have a
meditation application that
has little hummingbirds in it,
and one of those hummingbirds
floats up with its
little hummingbird beak
right next to your eye.
The user is going to recoil
away and defensively block,
and that was not what you wanted
because this was a meditation
application.
You're supposed to be relaxed.
So the important thing
about environmental comfort
is to be intentional,
to in testing,
see the types of
things that people
find unnerving for various
reasons, to think about it
and then involve this as
part of your testing process.
You're not just doing
physiological comfort, but also
environmental comfort.
So a quick note
about perspective.
Almost all VR apps are
first person perspective,
which makes a lot of sense.
Third person perspective
is also really interesting.
This is an app called
RoboBliteration.
It's really fun.
You have this little spaceship
that you control with your head
and it moves on the
surface of an asteroid.
So I think third person
perspective games for VR
are also super compelling
and we're probably
going to see a lot more of them
be considered in the future
as well.
So moving on to
interaction design,
for a system like Cardboard,
basically, all interaction
is by moving your
head gaze at objects
and then clicking on them.
So you're casting this ray
out of your head to set focus.
Something we've found is when
people first try Cardboard,
they don't really
move their head
very much because they haven't
really realized it yet.
So they just hold Cardboard
up and they stand very still,
and that can be a little
frustrating as a designer
because you've
created all stuff.
So something to do
with is you just
have something interesting
offscreen just a little
bit in their field
of view, something
to course them to
took over at it,
then they'll realize
that head tracking works.
As soon as they've done even a
little bit of a head movement,
they get it and
they start looking
around all over the place.
And then as you have users
starting to look around,
think about designs
that actually
leverage the whole canvas.
We don't have to design
for these small, 2D devices
anymore, so we can create
interfaces that actually
surround and encompass
the user and do
these really creative things
that haven't been possible
in the past.
There's tremendous
opportunity here.
There's also some challenge
because the camera
has free will.
So from the perspective
of a director
or a cinematographer
where they're
very focused on
telling their story
and controlling
everything, they're
probably a little bit
scared of the fact
that users can look anywhere.
How are we going
to deal with that?
So there's a couple ways of
directing the user's attention.
One of them is sort of
a brute force approach,
just rotation on scene change.
So say it's a spherical
video and the user's
looking at a particular spot,
but the next spot that's
interesting is off to the side.
As you're doing that scene
change and fading to black,
you can actually just
rotate that sphere
so that wherever
the user's looking,
the next interesting thing is
going to be in front of them.
Now, don't do the
rotation unless you're
fading to black because that
could make the user very sick,
having the world
spin all of a sudden,
but that's one way of
directing the user's attention.
Another way which is more subtle
is guiding the user with light.
This is a really popular
one in video game design.
So for people that are designing
levels for video games,
you'll often notice that
you just know the right way
to go through a level.
You usually find the right
path and keep walking.
If you're not paying
attention and you go back,
you'll see that often, they're
really lighting your path very
clearly, and that's how you just
intuitively know the right way
to go, these very subtle
cues with the lighting.
So we actually
have some examples
about this in the
Cardboard Design Lab
you can try out where people are
looking at the brightest parts.
Another thing we've been
exploring is gaze cues.
So this is where you're tracking
where the user's looking,
this ray that
they're casting out,
and then that's actually
having an impact
on the world around them.
So we have an example where
you look at constellations
and they illuminate, which
is sort of an interesting way
to make the world slightly
interactive with how
the user is looking at
things and exploring
more details of the world.
You can also use gaze cues
as a very technical technique
as you're staging things
out in your VR application.
So in the lab
right before, we're
actually teaching spatial
audio, the bell thing,
although in this
case, it's not a bell.
We have an owl.
When you look at the fire,
that triggers the owl appearing
because at this point,
we know that you're
looking at the fire.
And we know you're going
to look at the fire
because it's the
brightest thing.
So we're actually staging
the owl coming out
off of a gaze queue, and
then the owl shows up.
It's sort of a jump scare owl.
It's kind of fun.
So the final thing about
interaction design.
Let's talk about in
world user interfaces.
So the important thing
to note with VR design
is you can design
the whole world,
so you don't have
to build interfaces
in that world for the user to
use as much as you can actually
embody those interfaces
in the world itself.
So one developer in the
industry spoke about this
as don't have a
little health bar--
say you're flying a spaceship.
Instead, look out and
actually see the damage
on the wing of your spaceship.
That's a much more
interesting and compelling way
to convey that same information.
Don't have all these
little meta indicators
that are built in
because you can actually
expose that interface
in the world design.
And across the board, as we've
been doing all of this design
work, something we found is that
VR is a really powerful medium.
And there's three
things that happened
to be recently that
convinced me of this,
just fundamentally convinced
me VR is incredibly powerful.
The first one is
I actually forgot
I was in VR, which is maybe
a little embarrassing.
This was a couple weeks ago.
So I was sitting in a
movie theater simulation.
I was at work, and I
was watching trailers,
and I hadn't seen
the trailers yet,
so they were kind
of interesting.
And then I was really worried
because I haven't started
preparing for my I/O talk yet.
So I've got multiple
levels of distraction going
on there with the trailers
and also the worrying,
and then some people right
next to me started talking,
and I turned, and
there was no one there.
And I thought, that's weird.
It's not right.
And then I realized, oh,
it's because I'm in VR.
That was the first time
that happened to me.
So I think with
enough distraction,
our minds are set
up to start taking
the input they're getting.
So you can have
these moments where--
I mean, we have this even
when you're reading a book,
you get lost in the
story of the book,
so it's very easy for people
to get lost in things.
But getting lost in
VR is quite something.
The second thing that we
found very interesting
as a team is the
industry has talked a lot
about presence, this
notion of accepting
the simulation as reality for
a moment and rolling with it.
Even more interesting
is pairing presence
with the psychological
concept of flow
where your creativity is
just completely engaged.
In this case, with the
application Tilt Brush,
you're just lost,
not just in VR,
but you're also lost
in the creative task
of sculpting and painting.
And this can be a really
interesting experience
when you just spend long periods
of time creating things in VR.
And then the third thing
that's really struck me
about VR interface
design is when
you're thinking back
to VR experiences
you had a long time ago.
So because you're engaging
so much of your mind,
like all of your spatial
memory, your sense of self
is being engaged with VR,
you know it's not real
and you can think back and you
know it wasn't real back then,
but you're still storing
a lot of that experience
as if it was a place
or as if it was a thing
that you actually did.
So thinking back to
VR, you're really
for the first time
creating users' memories,
and this is amazing
as a designer
because now we can really
design rich experiences
that people think of as
places and as experiences
that they've had.
So this is something the team's
incredibly excited about.
Current contributions
so far, of course,
go get the Cardboard
Design Lab to try out
a lot of the VR principles.
We also have a lot of
documentation online,
and of course, the
SDK is available.
And with that, we
have a few minutes
left to take your questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JON WILEY: Any questions?
No?
Microphone right there.
Going once.
Can you get to the microphone
so we can get it on video?
No pressure.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked about how
you need 60 pixels per degree.
If you change the
field of view--
I think you mentioned this, but
you changed the field of view
in the latest Cardboard
upgrade and so that changed
the requirements.
If the field of view is wider
but you have the same device,
are you stretching it further?
ALEX FAABORG: Yeah.
So the pixels per
degree will actually
go down if you're increasing
the field of view.
AUDIENCE: Then how much
of this is lens specific?
If I have the Gear
VR Oculus headset,
are those lenses different
than the Cardboard
lenses and the apps need to be
designed entirely differently?
ALEX FAABORG: So for the
Works With Cardboard program,
the user will scan a
QR code on the device
and that communicates all
of the object's information
so the developer doesn't have
to worry at all about all
the objects out there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you all for your amazing
insights into VR and Cardboard.
I'm a little piggybacking
off of the prior question.
I wanted to ask your thoughts
on a user's experience
in Cardboard versus something
like Gear or Oculus,
and perhaps something that
is a more high fidelity
in the actual experience,
and your thoughts
on the differences
between designing there
and what you recommend
for users to really get
that first amazing experience
that doesn't have nausea,
that accounts for
parallax effect,
and those types of things.
JON WILEY: Yeah.
I think there's a spectrum
of capability of devices
out there, and so taking
into account the capability
of the device is important.
For Cardboard, we tend to
think of it as snackable VR.
It's not for long
duration experiences.
Really, if you're going
to, as I was saying
at the very top of it, which is
every capability that you add
increases the constraints
around making sure
it's golden in terms
of the experience.
And so you can create
a richer experience
with a more capable
device, but you just
have to be extra, extra
careful to make sure
that the experiences
is really living up
to the expectations
of the device.
So with devices like
Cardboard, at least today,
given today's mobile
phone technology,
it doesn't have
the full six degree
of freedom tracking that
you move around in a space,
so you just have to
be cognizant of that
and designing for the
limitations of the device.
I actually think
that the best designs
come from not working
against the system
but working with the system
to create a good experience.
And so if you've got a
high end system that you're
designing for, that's awesome.
You can create amazing content.
But I still think
that amazing content
can be created on more
restrictive systems
if it's playing to the
strengths of that system.
I think we've got
time for one more.
AUDIENCE: You kind of touched
on a little bit of user input
and, you have
basically one button
to interact with the system.
Are there any plans
to up that ante
to maybe allow users to
be more specific on input,
like typing or voice
or things like that?
JON WILEY: So I think part
of the magic of Cardboard
is the simplicity of
the system, and in fact,
with the version we
announced yesterday,
we actually made it a
lot easier to assemble.
So if anything, with
Cardboard, we're
going to keep pushing
to make it more simple.
But that said, we just
showed the Tilt Brush example
and the notion of
presence and flow.
Like with Tilt Brush, if
you can try Tilt Brush,
I highly recommend it
because you can really
get that sense of
working with your hands
and working in space
and things like that.
But as I was saying in
the previous question,
every single time you
raise the capability,
raise the expectations
for the experience,
you have to be extra
careful to make
sure you're designing for that.
So that's one of
the reasons why we
want to keep Cardboard really
simple because that's actually
playing to the strength
of a great experience
for a Cardboard class.
MANUEL CLEMENT: I just
wanted to add Cardboard,
you put it very
quickly on your face
for a snackable experience.
Your hands are also busy
holding it and then handing it
to your friend, like, oh my
gosh, this looks amazing.
So your hands are this
very social experience.
So your hands are
used there already,
so it's something to think
about as you build experiences.
Your hands will be on there.
AUDIENCE: On that note,
is length of experience
a factor that developers
should-- like length of time
that the experience lasts?
JON WILEY: Yeah.
I think for Cardboard, you
want it to be, as I said,
snackable experiences, so more
like more traditional YouTube
content versus like a long
form experience of Cardboard.
Thanks, everybody,
for coming out.
[APPLAUSE]